now this is the best part about using
cardboard i always have plenty to work
with
hi my name is warren king i'm a former
engineer
turned artist and i've been making
cardboard sculptures for the last seven
years
before i designed hospitals and parking
structures and stadiums for several
years
but today i make figurative sculptures
my work has been shown in museums and
galleries around the world
i made these sculptures with only
cardboard
glue and a knife today i'm going to show
you how to make a robot helmet with
tools that you likely already have at
home
first we're going to make the ring then
the comb the side combs the top of the
skull the sides of the skull the front
of the helmet the jawbone
and then the antenna here's the tools
that you'll be using
a hot glue gun scissors
a snap off blade a pencil
a circular object about four or five
inches in diameter
toilet paper roll and a cutting board
and of course you'll need cardboard
i use a standard shipping box
which is about two feet by six feet as
far as working table tops
i have a piece of plywood to protect my
table top
or you can use a regular kitchen cutting
board okay now we're going to start by
breaking down our box
grab your snap off plate i use a smaller
snap off blade
you can use the larger wider ones as
well i would prefer the smaller ones
because it allows me to get a little bit
more detailed circular cuts
so we're going to break down our box and
basically what we want
is three pieces that are the larger size
so that we can have
the larger parts of the helmet the tops
and the sides
just cut along the creases that way you
can have large pieces that don't have
folds
in the middle of the piece so just
carefully cut
it doesn't have to be very precise and
that's just a little bit easier to work
with
we're going to break this down to
smaller pieces so when we break this
down
we want to make sure that we cut along
the natural seams
of the creases of the cardboard
just cut it down into smaller pieces
and we're ready to go the cardboard
actually has three layers
a layer of paper a layer of corrugation
which is the waving material
in the middle and then another layer of
paper so if you look at the cardboard
there actually is a front and a back
the front usually has the printing and
you'll notice that the paper
is a little higher quality from the back
and the second thing that
we need to be aware of is the lines of
the corrugation
so if you look carefully at the back
then you can see that the corrugation
peeks through and you can see the lines
when we bend the cardboard
we want to bend it according to the
lines first we're going to make a ring
that goes around the forehead
now this is a piece that goes on the
inside of the helmet so it won't be seen
but it helps to hold everything together
so it just needs to be about an inch and
a half or two inches thick
and goes around the outside of your head
like a crown
the exact dimensions are not important
at this point so just take the longest
piece that we have
and cut a strip when you cut a strip
we're going to be
bending it into a curve like so now this
is the first tip about bending cardboard
whenever you want to make a curve you
want to make sure that the lines go in a
certain direction
because to bend it basically we fold it
along those creases
so i cut a strip out i've curved it a
little bit
to go around the head and i know that
it's a little bit too short still
right i still need about six inches or
seven inches so we'll just cut another
strip
be aware of the lines as usual and we'll
cut one
the same width bend it so it curves and
we'll just
splice it to this piece to give it the
correct length
so with hot glue what you want to make
sure of is that you
only use the amount of glue that you
really need so for a piece like this you
really only need to have
very tiny bit of glue just enough to
cover a surface
hold it in place and you have a piece
that's going to be long enough
now you can have a friend help you or
you can just do it yourself but you want
to just sort of measure
so that the ring fits around your head
not too tight you should be able to
still
slip a finger between your head and the
ring
use your scissors and snip off a little
bit of extra
again you leave a little bit of overlap
so you can glue
to remember where that line needs to be
just mark it off
and now i know where to apply the glue
now the glue gun that i'm using here
it's a professional level glue gun
right and what that means is that it's a
higher wattage
and the glue that comes out is at a
significantly
higher temperature now this is good
because the hotter the glue the stronger
the bond but if you don't have
a professional glue gun and you just use
the regular craft type
which is a lower wattage cooler glue
that's fine too it will work
now that we have the basic ring one
thing you'll notice is that the ring is
a little bit floppy
right it doesn't quite hold the shape
that we want the shape that we want is
not a circle
it's not elongated but it's sort of like
an oval egg shaped
the shape of your head so we're going to
use a technique to
keep the shape what composite laminates
are there are simply two layers of
material
that are bonded together it's the same
idea that you have when you
have a piece of plywood a plywood as you
can see
is multiple layers of wood but since
they're bonded together with a layer of
glue
then it holds a shape it's very firm and
it has a lot of structural integrity
we're going to put a continuous
layer of glue across the one face and
glue it
to the outside of our ring firmly
attach it make sure all the glue is
spread out
and before the glue cools down and dries
hold that shape hold it into place
wait the 10 or 15 seconds or so it takes
to
cool down and now when you let go
you find that the shape holds itself
the next part is we're going to start
building the top of the helmet
starting with this top piece which we'll
call the comb grab one of the larger
pieces of cardboard
and get a piece that's about six inches
wide by about 14 inches long
you should notice that the lines of the
corrugation run this direction
what this piece is going to look like is
it's going to have a bit of a taper
it's going to be about five and a half
inches at the widest part
tapering down to about three and a half
inches at one end
okay so we have a piece that's tapered
it's about 14 inches long and it's going
to go across the top of the helmet like
so
but we're not going to use a flat piece
it's going to be curved like the top of
the head so we use our curving
techniques again
so that's all you need at this point
don't worry about the exact shape
i'm taking our ring we're going to glue
this piece on like so this is going to
be the front of the helmet
this is the back on the back of the
helmet i just want to leave
maybe an inch inch and a half of
overhang there
on the front we want to make sure that
there's a little bit more overhang
because
there's a little bit of like a visor
piece that goes in the helmet i'm going
to eyeball it
make sure that it's centered and i'm
going to glue the back
once the back is glued then i can adjust
the curve
and then just figure out how to glue the
front okay
just hold it in place roughly just make
sure it's lined up
and centered and we wait our 10 or 15
seconds
so we want to make sure that this curve
is angled enough to allow your head to
sit comfortably in there
figure out how curved you want that
piece to be
so once you have an idea so we've made a
little mark
we apply just a little bit of glue there
just a drop
now we glue the front once the glue is
cooled down we're just going to trim
this down to a little bit more of a
size that we need and now that looks
much more even
now the next step is to make the sides
of this piece that we're calling the
comb we cut off a piece of cardboard
flat piece that's about 11 by four
right and i wanted to extend down a
little bit further
so that i can cover up this area as well
what i'm going to do
is cut out a little notch here so that
it slips down
right and i'll just make it about an
inch and cut it across there
just make sure it's relatively tight fit
right and right now it looks pretty good
so that's where i'm going to glue it
now i'm just covering up that space but
you notice all these extra pieces still
sticking out don't worry about that yet
use very little glue this is much less
glue than you would expect to make
just a few drops every half inch or so
is enough to hold that piece on
once it's held on and the position is
correct and once it's strong enough
then we trim it away grab your larger
scissors and trim away the big chunks
this is where it is very handy to have
two different size scissors when i have
a longer scissors with a longer blade
and do long very precise straight cuts
now when i want to
trim along a curve where it requires a
little bit more
precision that's where i use my other
pair of scissors that has a much shorter
blade length and then we'll do the same
for the other side
now the next piece is going to be
these horizontal pieces that we're
calling
the top of the skull you notice that
these pieces aren't quite parallel with
the top of the
comb right here they're slightly angled
downward so keep that in mind
we're going to adjust for that the piece
of cardboard that we'll need we'll make
about
4 inches by 12 inches and let's curve it
up
crease in between the lines of the
corrugation we start to get that nice
curved shape
notice that if i angle this down the way
i want it
there's a gap at the top so in order to
close up that gap
that means i need to sort of trim away
these corners
you can see it's a little bit of a curve
i'm going to hold it up to my helmet
so i can see i got pretty lucky with
that first cut so i'm going to glue this
on
and leave about an inch of space between
that top layer
and this layer okay and there we have it
we're going to hold off on trimming this
off until the other side is done
done the next part is to do
the sides of the skull one thing you
want to notice about this
is the orientation of these sides notice
that they're
fairly parallel and they're sticking
pretty close to straight down
so keep that in mind as we build this
part i'm going to cut off pieces that
are going to be
on each side we've cut off pieces about
six by eight
this is the front and have that facing
you at this point
put it right in front of you draw lines
that go down
that are roughly parallel we're going to
trim away some of that so let's do the
other side
and we just want to make sure that line
is fairly
parallel and it's close enough
to the sides and it's ready for glue
okay hold it so
now we take our larger scissors if
you're using two scissors
and trim away the big chunks
do the same thing for this side
switch to my more precise scissors
okay now we're going to move on to
the front of the helmet and the first
step to do that is to trim away some of
this
top part of the skull we can start to
use our pencil and just mark off where
we want to cut
so this visor piece is going to
basically come to the
top part of your brow right at the
bridge of the nose so you can see where
your bridge of the note is going to be
based on that ring that you had
so i want to bring this visor back and
then sort of have it flare back
okay and then where it hits this edge
then this part is going to curve back a
little bit
same thing with this side and then you
grab your scissors
and you start to trim away these extra
pieces of cardboard
starting to look like a helmet front
make sure it's still fitting okay and
now we're ready to
attach the face plate the face plate is
going to be a long piece
18 or 20 inches long and for this one
the corrugations have to run
in this direction because we're going to
be curving it like this
we crease all the way down okay
so now things are current one thing we
want to do here is you notice
this face plate here is curved but at
the middle there's a very hard
sharp angle so pick one of the grooves
that is right in the middle and just
bend
it right and put a sharp angle there
squeeze it down a little bit now comes a
question of how to attach it to
the helmet so get it all positioned with
both hands
and then we'll glue one side once that
side is glued
then we'll worry about the other side
and let's mark off
where that needs to be so take a line
here i put a line around the edge
i put another line like this so now i
know when i glue it
i line up that x there and that's
exactly where i need it to be
so once i have that glued in then i can
worry about the other side
so all this extra cardboard back here i
don't really need so i'm going to trim
that off
we add some glue and then i go back
use my guide lines here line it up
just like i had before right bottom edge
against this line this other line
for the other orientation and glue it on
okay i've glued one side
now i do the same thing with the other
side
we're good now we're going to
beef up this visor a little bit one
thing that
i don't like about it quite yet is that
you can see the thickness of the
cardboard so what i always like to do
and i do this in my own work is i put a
little return
on these pieces here to give the
illusion that this has
mass that it has thickness so find a
strip of cardboard
what we need is a little bit of strip
two inches wide and seven inches long
something that will be long enough to
cover a little bit of that
inside piece there okay so let's curve
this up a little bit
and we're going to take our pencil
and just mark off where that's going to
be
and trim that away
some glue
glue that on now we do the same thing
for the other side a little bit of
excess there
and that gives it that thickness
and that's basically it now the next
step is to make the antenna first we're
going to build the antenna
and then the next step we're going to
attach it to the actual helmet now the
first part of the antenna
is this circular plate that goes to the
side
and then we're going to build these
things up stick onto that plate for that
circular piece
find something that's you know roughly
this size five inches in diameter
take your piece of cardboard and we're
going to use that to trace out
the right shape make two of them one for
each side
and we can go ahead and cut that out and
cut off
the big chunks and then use the scissors
for the precision stuff
so this circle is going to go right on
the side here
and later on we'll make it swivel but
for now this is just going to be the
base onto which we attach the antenna
so for this piece the antenna it's got
two wings attached and each of these
wings is basically
a long strip of cardboard folded onto
itself
i'll just cut this right down the middle
one thing i should point out is the
corrugations
right since i'm making a bend in the
cardboard
the long way i want to have the
corrugations run this way
right not this way i just make that
crease down that
groove of the corrugation
i like to fold it down and i have a nice
clean joint so let's go ahead and make
two of these
put the circle in front of you and you
can start to eyeball
how this is going to be so just line
this up as best you can
and then use your pencil and just
indicate where you're going to trim that
away these pieces i don't want them to
overlap like this i want them to fit
together nicely
and just cut down that line cut all the
pieces together
that's the easiest way a couple of
strokes
yup that looks pretty good
and now let's cut this curve and i'm
just going to cut through both pieces of
cardboard at the same time
we're going to attach this piece and
that's looking pretty good now let's
design the top
the top i want to have a taper a little
bit right this is the thickest
piece and i wanted to taper down so that
it becomes a little bit pointier at the
end
so let's just cut it right through
let's glue these together it's it's
going to be sandwiched like this
so i'm just going to glue this shut with
a little bit of glue on each
side glue it here a little bit of glue
there
and let's just hold it to look loose
instead of having the antenna be
straight back and forth in a parallel
way i kind of want them to flare out
like this
when i glue this onto that plate i don't
want to glue them flat i'm going to glue
them
lift it up a little bit just a little
bit to do that
grab a little piece of scrap just add a
little layer here
maybe two so that when you glue this on
it points up a little bit okay so now
it's time to glue this on
i'm gonna do one side at a time put some
glue here
let's go ahead and glue that there's a
little bit of glue
and now i'm going to do the same thing
for the other side
okay now that we've made the ears now
we're going to attach them
to the sides of the head we want to make
it so that it can swivel
but first you want to find out
approximately where that ear is going to
sit and you go back to your original
round template and just draw
a circle basically where that's going to
sit
and the way this is going to work is
it's going to stick onto the side
of the helmet but it's going to have an
axle
and the axle is going to go through a
hole outside of the hole will have a
piece of cardboard to
prevent it from slipping back out the
toilet paper roll is
just the right diameter for that axle
but it's a little flimsier than i would
like
so we're just going to beef this up a
little bit before we use it
cut a strip that's just maybe
an inch in width
and we're just going to use it to line
the inside
of that toilet paper roll
and once it's in there and it's glued in
it gives it a little bit of extra
thickness for now we can just puncture
it
and just cut off we're going to be
further trimming this so don't worry
about a clean cut there
let's go ahead and cut the hole that we
need for this put it right in the middle
of that
larger ring that you drew and draw a
ring around the outside
and cut out that hole
let's make sure that it fits basically
it's going to sit like that so what
we're going to do is
on the back side of this we're going to
glue a slightly wider piece of cardboard
a circle piece
so it doesn't slip back out i like to
round it off just a little bit
just so it doesn't snag on anything as
it spins
but we're just going to glue this on as
an axle
and glue that down so let's test it out
going from the back we push this through
and that sits right so use your pencil
and just mark off the very lowest edge
of that
circle take your precise scissors and
just
trim down as close to that line as
possible
so just a little bit of that ring is
left we put some glue on
not too much and make sure the glue
doesn't flow to the outside of that
circle
if the glue flows to the outside of that
circle then it's going to be glued on to
the side
of the helmet and you won't be able to
spin it center that up
you want to make sure you hold it on
there long enough for it to
fully cool down you don't want it to
pull apart too early
because this actually needs to be a
fairly strong bond looks like it's
strong enough
right so now you have that spinning
action
opposable ears okay
now we do the same thing for the other
side
okay we have learned how to
curve the cardboard how to attach
different pieces of cardboard together
swiveling joints and we've learned how
to
give the illusion of mass with the
figures that you've built
the cardboard that i use is this pale
blue material
that is actually archival since i want
my artwork to
last for years and years this is the
material that i use some of the details
that i
added we have a mohawk here which is
just a bent piece of cardboard stuff to
the top
i added some more interesting details
to the antenna and these are just flat
strips of cardboard with
a few things that are sticking up and i
added the chin guard
that gives it a little bit of a change
in shape and i just filled in some of
these
holes here with additional strips of
cardboard but all that stuff is
simple stuff using the skills that we
went over today and you can
decide what to do with those on your own
i'm warren king
thanks for joining me and good luck
making your own cardboard creations